La froguine...
Est un succès.
C'est une catastrophe.
On vend beaucoup.
Les gens sont accros.
On est blindé.
On fait le mal.
Je suis super content !
Je suis qu'une merde.
Je suis en pleine forme !
Je veux plus faire ça.
Yorel.
Oui ?
Pardon.
Suivant.
Bienvenue à la première réunion de la résistance.
Donc on s'appelle pas "tabouret" alors ?
Non, finalement non.
Ce que nous voulons, c'est que je récupère mon trône.
Ouais.
Ouais !
Ouais, ouais.
Eh non, c'est pas ce qu'on avait dit.
On avait dit moins d'impôts.
Et plus de liberté.
Parce que sinon, c'est juste un seigneur qui remplace un autre.
Oui, oui, oulala, non, non, non.
Tu te trompes petit singe très laid.
Non, non, non !
Là, c'est la démocratie.
Ça a rien à voir. C'est vous qui m'avais élu chef.
On a fait ça quand ?
Mais si, souviens-toi...
Et le roi ?
Il essaye de te rendre plus heureux ?
Ah bah oui ! Et il nous file ça.
En plus, le premier est gratuit.
Non mais attendez, c'est pas parce que c'est gratuit qu'il faut le prendre.
Mais non, c'est de la merde !
Ça c'est un piège, c'est pas bien ça.
Ouais mais il paraît que ça fait oublier les problèmes.
Non, non, non.
Il faut pas oublier les problèmes.
Faut résoudre les problèmes.
Classe !
On veut plus de bouffe ou pas ?
Ah oui, oui, oui !
Voilà !
Les mystères sont... Pardon.
La résistance !
Allez décroche, tu décroches.
Oui.
Tout d'abord...
Nous avons encore battu notre propre record de vente de froguine.
Applaudissement pour Yorel et son formidable travail.
Mais justement, aux vues des effets secondaires de la drogue... de la froguine !
Je me demandais, s'il serait pas un peu plus sage...
D'en réduire, un tout petit peu, les ventes.
On va pas faire ça.
On est en train de devenir riche.
Oui, j'entends bien mais je crois que ça rend les gens un peu malade.
Riche !
Est-ce qu'on pourrait pas, au moins, cet argent pour rendre la vie du peuple un peu plus agréable ?
Ils sont pas heureux là ?
Avec toute la froguine qu'ils s'envoient !
Ils doivent voir des couleurs incroyables.
Des farfadets.
Des licornes.
Non, je veux parler de l'instauration des bals.
Pour que les villageois rencontre leur mari.
De façon un peu plus civilisée.
On en avait parlé déjà !
On en avait parlé mais là, si tu veux, on en reparle demain.
Viens, on profite, c'est la fête.
Non, je veux qu'on en parle maintenant !
Tu as dit que tu étais d'accord pour ça !
L'argent va nous servir à acheter une armée.
Pas des ballerines !
Viens pas pisser sur ma parade Clarisse, t'es chiante !
Tu veux quoi à la fin ?
Je veux l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes !
Très bien.
Laisse-moi juste un peu de temps pour m'organiser.
Je te promets que ton voeux sera exaucé.
Mes braves, si nous voulons récupérer le pouvoir...
Il faut chasser le seigneur dragon du trône.
Est-ce que vous connaissez le point faible d'un dragon ?
L'oreille interne.
Son jeu de jambes.
Non, non, la tête, la tête. Il faut lui couper la tête !
Mais ça c'est le point faible de tout le monde.
Oui mais non, pour que le corps s'effondre il faut lui couper la tête.
Ça reste un dragon, moi je suis pas hyper chaud quand même, hein.
C'est que la masse du truc...
Non, non, non. J'ai un plan, j'ai un plan !
On réunit un maximum de paysans et de villageois...
Pour former la révolution.
On va au château.
On passe par un passage secret, que seul moi et quelques prostituées on connait.
Je me suis auto-balancé, c'est pas grave.
On va dans la château.
On coupe la tête du dragon.
Et on aura plus de bouffe !
La résistance !
Aelys, tu voulais me voir ?
Ah ! Clarisse !
Je suis content.
C'est un grand jour pour toi.
Ah bon ?
Oui.
Tu m'as souvent dit que tu voulais être l'égale d'un homme.
C'est ça, hein ?
Oui, qu'il y est plus de différence.
Plus de privilèges.
- Plus de différences, parfait. C'est exactement ça.
Et bah figure-toi que j'ai négocié avec ce monsieur...
Pour qu'il n'y est plus de différences entre un homme et toi.
Mais en plus, je vais gagner de l'argent pour mon armée au passage.
C'est-à-dire ?
Je t'ai vendu.
Quoi ?
3000 pièces.
Non ?
Si.
C'est pas possible, c'est une blague !
Tu vois le gars là ?
Qui a l'air un peu triste.
Et bah tu vas être son égale, pas plus, pas moins.
Bon !
Allez, moi je dois y aller !
Emmenez-là !
Aelys, on peut discuter, sois raisonnable !
Non, non ! Aelys !
Aelys ! Aelys !
Non ! Non ! Aelys !
J'ai dit 3000 pour pas la vexer.
Mais j'ai pas pu avoir plus que 1500 et des bottes.
Le mec qu'à l'oeil.
Vous êtes prêt à faire cette révolution ?
Ouais !
Le pouvoir au peuple !
Coupons la tête du dragon !
Ouais !
Allez ! Allez !
J'ai des espions.
Pas de complots.